[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News Tonight live from Kiev
a special program on the deepening
crisis here in Ukraine
soldiers on high alert and residents
defiant we report from the front line as
Russia is accused of an invasion of
eastern Ukraine
concern though that this is just the
beginning as Putin blames Ukraine for
the crisis and the Russian Parliament
gives him permission to deploy troops
President Biden is expected to announce
U.S sanctions against Russia when he
speaks shortly we'll bring that to you
live
and the UK targets five banks and three
oligarchs but warns it will go much
further if Russia does not pull back
Putin is implacably determined to go
further
in subjugating and tormenting Ukraine
[Music]
good evening from Kiev the capital of a
country on high alert tonight amid what
the West is calling a Russian invasion
the International Community issued its
response today in the form of sanctions
after Vladimir Putin ramps up tensions
by recognizing the independence of two
rebel-held areas but there are fears
that could be just the beginning after
Russia's Parliament rubber stamped
Putin's request to send Armed Forces
abroad it formalizes the deployment of
what the Russian president called
peacekeepers in eastern Ukraine but
could also suggest he intends to launch
a broader attack
the contested donbass region
internationally recognized as part of
Ukraine but with an enclave of Russian
separatists last night Vladimir Putin
recognized the independence of two
Breakaway republics in Donetsk and
luhansk the separatists only control
about one-third of the regions but with
military backing there's now concern
that Russian troops have crossed the
border and may push further into Ukraine
Sky correspondent Alex Rossi reports now
from pisky a village on the line of
control between the rebels and Ukraine
foreign
Skies they move amidst the wrecked
buildings waiting for an attack they
think could come at any moment the front
line is increasingly Moody it's tense
with expectation
the soldiers know this conflict is
Shifting and they fear the might of
Vladimir Putin's Army is massing not far
away in the areas held by russian-backed
separatists
the Kremlin calls the soldiers a
peacekeeping force but the commander
here tells me that is just another
deception is
um
or has been grinding on for eight brutal
and unforgiving years this Memorial to a
Ukrainian mortar unit sits desolate in
the shadow of a smashed up school
all along these front lines there are
reminders that death is never far away
and the abandoned buildings tell their
own stories of lives changed Forever by
this conflict
please
we've just heard the sound of fire in
the background we've come into this
school for cover
this has been abandoned in the fighting
all of this town here we're close to
Donetsk airport now the soldiers we're
with they are worried about what has
happened with Vladimir Putin's
recognition of the Breakaway regions
they think that
this may really be the eve now of a big
Invasion into this area by Russian
forces
it is hard to convey just how close the
villages are to the front lines this one
is regularly hit by artillery but
amazingly people still live here they
are the old and the infirm
people like 83 year old stepper nivna
who have nowhere else to go
Ukraine is a country under psychological
and physical Siege the soldiers here say
the sanctions will not be enough to
deter further Russian aggression and
they know they may soon have to fight to
defend these positions as the Kremlin
redraws the map of Eastern Europe
Alex Rossi Sky News near Donetsk
so the White House has described
Russia's actions as an invasion of
Ukraine Paving the way then for U.S
sanctions President Biden is expected to
hold a news conference at the white
house shortly and of course we will
bring that to you let's go live to the
White House and our correspondent Mark
Stone so Mark we've heard today from the
UK government we've heard from the EU
what are we expecting from Joe Biden
well the hope all along is that if they
had to impose sanctions then Western
nations would be able to impose a
package or individual packages of
sanctions which looked identical and
which could be imposed at the same time
in doing that they would be able to send
a clear United message to Vladimir Putin
that is not looking like it is going to
be possible the EU is taking a little
time to ratify the sanctions package
that they want to put through the
British sanction packet sanction package
is being criticized already in the UK
for not being strong enough and that the
expectation although we may find out
more when President boy will find out
more when President Biden speaks but the
expectation is that that what he will
announce will not be the full and
unprecedented sanctions that have been
talked about for so many weeks and I
guess the the reason for that it is
simple it's because they need to keep
something up their sleeve they cannot
roll out a full package now because what
happens if Vladimir Putin ignores that
again they've got nothing left because
they've said the Americans have said
repeatedly that military action within
Ukraine is simply not a possibility
because Russia is of course a nuclear
power so I expect we will see something
short of the full
um
extra special sanctions extraordinary
sanctions that have been talked about uh
we're not I don't think going to see uh
the um Russia cut off from the Swift
banking system for example if that was
the case then we would have seen similar
in the UK and in the EU as well but at
the same time President Biden has to
show that he is that he means business
he has to show some sense of strength
ultimately though Mark
um the sanctions threat and that's what
it was it was a threat of sanctions it
failed because President Putin knew that
sanctions of some sort would come and
yet he has ignored them I think what's
interesting is the the evolution of
language here in in Washington over the
course of the last 24 hours they were
talking about an incursion and now
they're talking more about an invasion
the deputy National Security advisor who
will be giving a briefing later said
look an invasion is an invasion and this
is an invasion but then he added uh
Russia has been invading Ukraine for
about eight years now so a sort of
caveat there I think simply they want to
be able to hold back some sanctions
options they don't want to be able to
roll have to have to roll them all out
together a very very difficult
unenviable situation and and at the
broader point is that watching President
Putin over the course of the past 24
hours as they have been so closely they
will wonder now if he ever was serious
about diplomacy or whether he might just
push on through into the rest of Ukraine
at some point anyway
okay Mark thanks very much indeed quick
look inside the White House that is a
Podium that requires an American
president when it gets one we will bring
him to you
now in Moscow today Vladimir Putin
rejected claims he had breached the
terms of the Minsk peace process saying
the agreement no longer existed because
of the actions of Ukraine and he issued
a list of Demands to end the crisis
calling for Crimea to be recognized as
part of Russia a halt to weapons
shipments to Ukraine and an end to the
country's bid to join NATO Moscow
correspondent Diana magnet reports now
on the Russian escalation
Russian flags and honking car horns in
the separatist city of Donetsk but this
bestowal of Independence which is not
Russia's gift to give will not
necessarily bring peace
Vladimir Putin declaring today he'd
recognized the separatists claims to the
whole of Donetsk and luhansk regions not
just the parts they control we have
recognized all fundamental documents and
their constitution and Constitution
determines the borders
while they were part of Ukraine but we
are counting on
on resolution of all these uh
differences the Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski whose territory this
is called for an immediate and tough
response
Europe and the world could not allow the
repetition of the tragic mistakes made
in Georgia in 2008. we agreed on the
necessity of immediately imposing
sanctions for another action of
aggression against Ukraine these
sanctions must include the complete
shutdown of Nordstrom II
and as if On Cue the German Chancellor
obliged
yeah
I've asked the German economy Ministry
today to withdraw the report on the
analysis of the energy Supply guarantees
from the German regulator it sounds
technical but it's the required
procedure so that there can be no
certification of the pipeline now
without this certification nordstream 2
can't become operational
Russia's Upper House has now authorized
the deployment of the Russian armed
forces in the separatist republics as
and when it's deemed that they're needed
but are they already there
[Music]
unmarked military convoys on the roads
of the republics last night though not
much to go on Beyond these pictures
declaring the Breakaway Republic's
independent is one thing pushing further
into Ukraine is another both are clearly
invasions of Ukrainian sovereignty but
one would involve a lot more Bloodshed
the question is is Vladimir Putin a
rational actor or has he let his
emotions and the bubbling resentments of
years if not decades get the better of
him
again he returned to an imaginary threat
of a one-day nuclear Ukraine
cranes in Soviet times had quite an
extensive
nuclear competences they've got several
nuclear units and their nuclear industry
is well developed 110 kilometers can be
increased to 300 to 500 kilometers and
then Moscow will be within the
the reach of these rockets for us this
is a strategic threat Ukraine gave up
its nuclear weapons 30 years ago in
exchange for security assurances from
the likes of Russia
President Putin first broke those
promises eight years ago in Crimea and
he continues to trample on them now
Sky News Moscow
well Boris Johnson today announced what
he called the first barrage of sanctions
against allies of Vladimir Putin and
Russia's financial institutions three
oligarchs and five Russian Banks were
targeted with measures including UK
asset freezes and a ban on British
businesses dealing with them and the
foreign secretary Liz truss says the
government is prepared to go much
further if Russia does not pull back our
political Elizabeth Rigby reports now on
the UK response and a warning it
contains flash photography
nobody Sleeps when Europe's on the brink
of War isn't Russia Unstoppable now
the foreign secretary arriving Before
Sunrise an emergency Cobra meeting
convened in the early hours and a
promise to punish Putin if
Vladimir Putin continues Dan this track
of a violence of aggression of a
full-scale invasion of encircling Kiev
itself which is what he seems to be
proposing to do capturing the Ukrainian
Capital it is absolutely vital that that
effort that that conquest of another
European country should not succeed and
that Putin should fail and that is what
we will be exerting ourselves to
ensuring is is the outcome will
sanctions be enough to stop putting
prime minister
an attempt to answer that question in
the Commons as the PM announced limited
sanctions today the UK is sanctioning
the following five Russian Banks rossia
is Bank General Bank a promise bank and
the black seed bank and we are
sanctioning three very high net worth
individuals this is the first Trash
the first barrage of what we are
prepared to do and we hold further
sanctions at Readiness the labor leader
Four Square behind the PM on the
principle but frustrated that strong
rhetoric hadn't translated into enough
real action we must be prepared to go
further if we do not respond with a full
set of sanctions now
Putin will once again take away the
message that the benefits of aggression
outweigh the costs
the complaint that current measures are
not enough widely shared it's not doing
anything said one MP the Prime Minister
taking notes as all sides of the house
called for heavier harsher measures we
need to hit them if we're going to hit
them with sanctions hard and hit them
now they need to feel the pain of the
first part of this decision we are
facing the growth of the axis of
totalitarian States my anxiety is that
we're not going anywhere near far enough
today in 2014 we were spineless in the
end can I urge the prime minister to go
further today President Putin has made a
terrible decision will the Prime
Minister make sure he pays a terrible
price the liberal Democrat leader urging
the prime minister to strip Russia of
Hasting the champion League final I
think it's inconceivable that major
International uh football tournaments
can take place in in Russia after as I
say the invasion of a sovereign country
foreign secretary the sanctions enough
a question being discussed behind this
door is the foreign secretary was
summoned to a second Cobra meeting of
the day good afternoon thank you for
what you're doing sanctions in London
British troops to Ukraine's neighboring
borders this was the PM visiting Army
Personnel in Poland just days ago and
today the government promising more
military help if necessary we're
absolutely open to doing even more if
required because we need to send that
clear signal to President Putin as I
have warned and warned the Kremlin for
weeks and months that as we knew in 2014
he gets the opposite of what he wants he
will get more forces on his borders and
just as he did in 2014 he will no doubt
get more spending on defense in NATO but
for all the rhetoric there was this
quiet in this place today over that
package of sanctions bringing a
peashooter to a gunfight is how one
foreign policy expert put it this is a
significant moment in the history of the
21st Century tree Europe stands on the
brink of war and our leaders simply
don't know whether Putin intends to go
on or take a step back
but what we do know is that in years to
come they will be judged on how they met
the moment and whether in that moment
they did enough there's an old military
Maxim which is clout don't dribble and
the reason you should hit hard early
is to make sure you're absolutely clear
that any escalation will hurt
there's no point in ratcheting up you
must make sure that there's an absolute
line and I'm afraid what we've done with
the sanctions today is introduce
sanctions of the U.S introduced four
years ago
PM will be considering the UK's next
move this the end of a very long and
dark day and the beginning of what could
be a protracted and bloody crisis Beth
Rigby Sky News Westminster
and Beth joins me now from Westminster
Beth I guess one of the problems is that
if sanctions are the only real weapon in
this crisis you've got to keep some key
ones back
yes Mark and that was what Mark in
Washington was just talking about wasn't
it as we wait to see what President
Biden has to say what has been going on
here today well as I was reporting the
Prime Minister and we've seen it in
recent days has been very strong
rhetorically in his warnings uh to
President Putin and also not mincing his
words on the gravity of the situation
the risk of Bloodshed and the protracted
crisis that Europe could now be entering
into with the decision by Putin to have
that incursion into those separatist
territories within Ukraine but what's
happening in the UK government is that
there is a appetite a desire to be in
lockstep with other allies so to go in
line with what other Western allies are
doing why because Western allies want to
prevent a uni united front to Putin but
domestically for Boris Johnson that has
thrown up problems today and that's
because and you saw it in the Commons
today across Parliament across all
parties uh MPS want him to go harder and
faster there is Russian money in London
and they want to see a ratcheting up of
sanctions and kierstama laid that out in
the house he said that Russia should be
uh excluded from the Swift mechanism it
should we should stop trading Russian
debt he said that the UK should get its
house in order and stop the illicit flow
of Russian Finance in to Britain and I
spoke to a couple of former cabinet
ministers about their perspective and
they said well they understood that
diplomatically Boris Johnson might want
to stay in lockstep with
um our allies our Western allies that
actually there's more Russian money in
in London and there's more financial
links than other countries and they do
too want to see a ratcheting up of
sanctions in order to say as one former
cabinet minister said to me well you put
the sanctions on now and then you tell
President Putin that you'll roll them
back if necessary as this unfolds so
there is huge pressure here to put more
sanctions in place but the Prime
Minister cleared too that this is just
the first round and they are now waiting
and watching to see how this unfolds
okay Beth thank you very much indeed
well the European union says it
unanimously agreed on the sanctions it's
imposed on Russia targeting Banks
accused of financing operations in
disputed Ukrainian territories
this package of sanctions that has been
approved by unanimity by the member of
states
will hurt Russia
and it will hurt a lot we agreed to
Target 27 individuals and entities
who are playing a role in undermining or
threatening Ukrainian territorial
Integrity sovereignty and independency
potentials are only part of our response
diplomatic efforts will continue
to avert a new eruption of War
conflict in the heart of Europe
live at Brussels under your
correspondent Adam Parsons and Adam it
does seem as if the EU have gone well
certainly further than the UK
yeah it does seem the way they've
introduced a raft of sanctions they have
done by EU standards done this pretty
quickly targeting 27 individuals and
entities I know that within that are
three substantial Banks but I think the
two standouts from this are number one
is nordstream two that pipeline running
from Russia to Germany we know the
Germans were reluctant to put that on
the table they did and then today rather
proactively that was the first big
standout sanction a second thing that
the European Union has done uh which I
think is very important is to say that
it will restrict Russia's access to
Europe's Capital markets now that sounds
uh pretty fustery but actually okay Adam
got to interrupt you we're going
straight to Washington and Joe Biden
foreign
well good afternoon
yesterday Vladimir Putin recognized two
regions of Ukraine as independent states
and he bizarrely asserted that these
regions are no longer part of Ukraine
and their Sovereign territory
to put it simply Russia just announced
that it is carving out a big chunk of
Ukraine
last night Putin authorized Russian
forces to deploy into the region of
these regions today he asserted that
these regions are actually extend deeper
than the two
areas he recognized claiming large areas
currently under the jurisdiction of the
Ukraine government
he's setting up a rationale to take more
territory by force in my view and if we
listened to a speech last night and many
of you did I know he's uh he's setting
up a rationale to go much further this
is the beginning of a Russian invasion
of Ukraine as he indicated and asked
permission to be able to do from his
Duma so let's begin to uh so I I'm going
to begin to impose sanctions in response
far beyond the steps we and our allies
and partners implemented in 2014 and if
Russia goes further with this Invasion
We Stand prepared to go further as with
sanctions
who in the lord's name does Putin think
gives them the right to declare new
so-called countries on territory that
belong to his neighbors
this is a flagrant violation of
international law and Demands a firm
response from the International
Community
over the last few months we've
coordinated closely with our NATO allies
and partners in Europe and around the
world to prepare that response
we settled along and I've told Putin to
his face some a month or more than a
month ago that we would act together
and the moment Russia moved against
Ukraine Russia is now undeniably moved
against Ukraine by declaring these
independent states
so today I'm announcing the first
tranche of sanctions to impose cost on
Russia in response to their actions
yesterday
these have been closely coordinated with
our allies and partners and will
continue to escalate sanctions if Russia
escalates we're implementing full
blocking sanctions on two large Russian
financial institutions
veb and their Military Bank we're
implementing comprehensive sanctions on
Russian sovereign debt
that means we've cut off Russia's
government from Western financing it can
no longer raise money from the west and
cannot trade in its new debt on our
markets or European markets either
starting tomorrow and continuing in the
days ahead we'll also impose sanctions
on Russia's Elites and their family
members
they share in the corrupt gains of the
Kremlin policies and should share in the
pain as well
and because of Russian's actions we've
worked with Germany to ensure Nordstrom
too will not as I promised will not move
forward
as Russia contemplates this next move we
have our next move prepared as well
Russia will pay an even steeper price if
it continues its aggression including
additional sanctions the United States
will continue to provide defensive
assistance to Ukraine in the meantime
and we'll continue to reinforce and
reassure our NATO allies
today in response to Russian's admission
that it will not withdraw its forces
from Belarus I have authorized
additional moments of U.S forces and
equipment already stationed in Europe to
strengthen our Baltic allies Estonia
Latvian Lithuania
let me be clear these are totally
defensive moves on our part
we have no intention of fighting Russia
we want to send an unmistakable message
though that the United States together
with our allies will defend every inch
of NATO territory
and abide by the commitments we made
into NATO
we still believe that Russia is poised
to go much further in launching a
massive military attack against Ukraine
hope I'm wrong about that hope we're
wrong about that but Russia has only
escalated his threat against the rest of
Ukrainian territory including major
cities and including the capital city of
key
there are there are still well over 150
000 Russian troops surrounding Ukraine
and as I said Russian forces remained
positioned in Belarus to attack Ukraine
from the north including warplanes and
offensive missile systems Russia's moved
troops closer to Ukraine's border with
Russia
Russia's Naval vessels are maneuvering
in the Black Sea to Ukraine South
including amphibious assault ships
missile Cruisers and submarines
Russia's moved supplies of blood and
medical equipment into position on the
border
you don't need blood unless you plan on
starting a war
over the last few days we've seen much
of the Playbook that secretary Lincoln
laid out last week in the United Nations
security Council come to pass
a major increase in Military
provocations and false flag events along
the line of contact in the Dom boss
dramatically staged conveniently on
camera meeting of Putin's Security
Council to grandstand for the Russian
public
and now political provocation of
recognizing Sovereign Ukrainian
territory as so-called independent
republics in clear violation again of
international law
President Putin has sought authorization
from the Russian Parliament to use
military force outside of Russian
territory and this set the stage for
further pretext of further provocations
by Russia to try to justify further
military action
none of us none of us should be fooled
none of us will be fooled there is no
justification
further Russian assault in the Ukraine
remains a severe threat in the days
ahead
and if Russia proceeds it is Russia and
Russia alone that bears the
responsibility
as we respond my Administration is using
every tool at our disposal to protect
American businesses and consumers from
rising prices at the pump as I said last
week defending Freedom will have cost
for us as well and here at home
we need to be honest about that but as
we will do but as we do this I'm going
to take robust action and make sure the
pain of our sanctions is targeted at a
Russian economy not ours
we're closely monitoring energy supplies
for any disruption we're executing a
plan in coordination with major oil
producing consumers and producers toward
a collective investment to secure
stability and Global energy supplies
this will be this will blunt gas prices
I want to limit the pain to the American
people are feeling at the gas pump this
is critical to me
in the last few days I've been in
constant contact with European leaders
including with Ukrainian president
zielinski vice president Harris met in
person with the leaders in Germany over
the weekend
at the Munich conference including
president zielinski at every step we
have shown the United States and our
allies and partners are working in
unison which he hasn't been counting on
Mr Putin we're United in our support of
Ukraine we are united in our opposition
to Russian aggression and we're United
in a resolved to defend our NATO
alliance and we're United in our
understanding of the urgency and
seriousness of the threat Russia is
making to Global peace and stability
yesterday
the world heard clearly
the full extent of Vladimir Putin
Twisted rewrite of History
going back more than a century as he
waxed eloquently
noting that well I'm not going to go
into it but nothing in Putin's length of
remarks indicate any interest in
pursuing real Dialogue on European
Security in the year 2022. he directly
attacked Ukraine's right to exist
he indirectly threatened territorial
formerly held by Russia including
Nations that today are thriving
democracies and members of NATO
he explicitly threatened War unless his
extreme demands were met
and there is no question that Russia is
the aggressor
so we're clear-eyed about the challenges
we're facing nonetheless there is still
time to avert the worst case scenario
that will bring Untold suffering to
millions of people if they move as
suggested
the United States and our allies and
partners remain open to diplomacy if it
is serious
when all is said and done
we're going to judge Russia by its
actions not its words
and whatever Russia does next we're
ready to respond with unity
Clarity and conviction
we'll probably have more to say about
this as we moves on I'm hoping diplomacy
is still available thank you all very
much
[Music]
so Joe Biden there with his uh Joe Biden
there announcing his sanctions and not
taking questions noticeably at the end
of that what did he have to say he said
that Russia is carving out a chunk of
Ukraine and he's setting out a rationale
he said to go much further than that who
in the lord's name thinks Putin has the
right to take territory from a
neighboring Country Joe Biden then
announced the sanctions cutting off
Russia he said from raising money from
the west and he also announced sanctions
on the Russian Elite and their family
members he said if he goes further we
will go further let's speak to our White
House go to the White House rather speak
to our U.S correspondent Mark Stone and
Mark noticeable at the end he said still
time to avert to the worst case scenario
we are ready to talk
yeah you know I mean it is admirable
um from a from his perspective that they
are keeping the door or the window wide
open
um for for door for dialogue for
diplomacy they are taking the moral High
Ground uh in that sense they are saying
as he did again that um any troops that
are deployed to the region and he did
point out that more Americans would be
buttressing as the to use the phrase
they've used before the Eastern flank
all those troops are defensive in nature
he's really pushing the point that that
the aggressor here is not the West it
never has been so he says and it never
will be the aggressor is Putin I think
tomorrow morning's headlines are
probably already been written by that uh
that line who in the lord's name does
Putin think he is gives Putin the right
to do this
um in terms of the detail of the
sanctions exactly as we expected not the
full um uh the full tranche or the full
package of sanctions that had been
suggested because it isn't a full
invasion this is the first trance of
tranche of of U.S sanctions and many
many more could be put in place so the
president said simply they have to keep
some sanctions up their sleeve they
can't impose them all now that's the
rationale that they are using they are
using them as a deterrent of course
they're well aware that the deterrent
has not worked so far because President
Putin has indeed uh tried or attempted
to Annex another part of Ukraine he is
putting forces within Ukraine's
territorial borders and and yet the
threat of sanctions were there and
President Putin has ignored them but
this is one tranche and I think it is
significant that he's um he's naming a
specific bank that he says will be
sanctioned the veb bank and its military
branch this is a a major Bank in the in
in
um Russia and it has the ability to do
trading with with banks in the United
States well that will cease that has
ceased as of now and he talked to about
Russian individuals that will be
sanctioned and will get the names of
those I'm sure in the detail that will
come out in the coming hours so so a
first tranche of sanctions the objective
is to try and appear United with the UK
with the EU and with other Western
Nations it's difficult though because
they all have their different types of
sanctions they all come out at slightly
different times the objective is to
appear United
Mark stone at the White House thank you
very much indeed well let's just get the
thoughts now of our panel this evening
as the West responds to what Joe Biden
calls an attack on Ukraine's right to
exist I'm joined by Sir Roderick line
former UK ambassador to Russia K Bailey
Hutchison who's a former U.S ambassador
to Nato and also senior advisor at the
center for strategic and international
studies and also the economist Anders
aslund who's a senior fellow at the
Stockholm free world forum and who knows
plenty about sanctions thank you all for
being with us and Sir Roderick if I
could I think start with you and the
question everybody wants an answer to
tonight what is President Putin up to do
you think
well it was interesting that President
Biden picked up on Putin's statement
yesterday uh nobody in Moscow Ever Knows
what's in Putin's mind but his statement
yesterday was rambling it was paranoid
uh it sounded at times almost unhinged
and the seal Moscow correspondent
rightly said just now there is a
question as to whether Putin is a
rational actor what he's just done is to
reinvade about three percent of
Ukraine's territory and rather absurdly
recognize it as independent nobody else
will follow him in that what he has
still left completely unclear is what
his next move will be uh and there will
be a number of factors in that I think
he will take note of the United Western
position I think if he's being rational
he will think very hard about the
effects within Russia I don't think the
Russian population want to see Russians
killing ukrainians uh he'll think about
the economic damage and he ought to
think about what China is is going to
say because China supported him in
opposing the expansion of NATO but China
has not supported him in the idea of
taking Ukraine and a strong message from
China could also be part of the
deterrent to President Putin
yeah it's a very interesting point there
Kay Bailey Hutchison just on one of the
points made do you think that President
Putin is a rational actor and how far do
you think he is going to go in this
I don't think he is rational but I also
don't think that we
can
measure him because our standards are so
different from his
we think that having the respect of the
world is important he doesn't
we think that human rights are important
he doesn't so I think we have to try not
to get in his shoes because we can't our
culture doesn't understand it that
taking over another Sovereign Nation is
absolutely against everything that we
stand for and that's what he's doing and
he has been very clear that Ukraine is
not another country that it is a Soviet
satellite and so I think we have to act
with strength and commitment I thought
the president's point that we are
coordinating with allies was very good I
think your government has already put in
sanctions so has the EU now we have
announced ours
um and I hope that those sanctions
against the banks and and also
that we would put trade embargoes uh on
Russia and what they could deliver out
to any of our countries will be
important to see if this makes enough of
a difference in his economy and his
Revenue stream uh that it will deter him
uh to going back to the Diplomatic table
just staying in the Don boss is is not
enough he has now invaded that country
he's disrupted that the all of those
regions that he is now saying are in his
domain and he has also made an agreement
with them that he will be putting
military bases in those two provinces
this is what he did in Georgia we would
look at that Playbook
yeah now Anders aslund are these the
right sanctions that we've been hearing
about today are they the right sanctions
at the right time
I would say but these are the right
sanctions and it's very good about
coming immediately which is the the
right time and the two Banks or
financial institutions that are being
sanctioned aren't quite important VB
could be described as uh President Putin
slash fund what he used is for
unexpected undertakings as financial
crisis or the social the finest out of
that from Sears bank is specialized on
the military industry so neither of
these Banks deal with the Russian people
so that's the first one today but more
should come as President Biden suggested
it's also good to take to complete this
sanction Uh Russian and sovereign debt
and it's excellent at North stream 2 uh
finally gets the sanction and it's also
good that it's done together with a
Germany so that it is being stopped it
remains to be seen who in the elite that
uh our sanctioned so far we have seen
that the most important people have
normally not been sanctioned and I'm
waiting with a great interest to see the
actual name that I presume will come out
later today or tomorrow
yeah we're still waiting for those names
sir Roderick uh back to you and I don't
know whether you saw it this bizarre
extraordinary security council meeting
that President Putin had yesterday and
chose to have uh on live television it
led me to wonder whether he has people
around him that can talk sense to him do
you have a view on that
uh yeah it was absolutely wacky and I
think you've touched on a real problem
when Putin first came into Power lots of
people went through his office uh and he
listened to a lot of people he's now
hiding away from the Russian people he's
existing in a little bubble and
surrounded by aging people of his own
generation many of them ex KGB or
ex-military steeped in Soviet Traditions
who are not challenging him there are
people many people in the Russian Elite
who are deeply unhappy with the policy
he's pursuing they include some Russian
generals who can do the mass and can see
that this would be a very ill-conceived
operation they can see another important
thing that Biden said was that he was
going to put further American forces
into the Baltic states Putin has
provoked the reinforcement of NATO's
Eastern flanks that's exactly the
opposite of what the Russian general
staff uh would have wanted to see but I
don't think that Putin
uh is listening to Serious advice
um he has the total power over decisions
of War and Peace and uh I think that's
quite a dangerous situation
Kate How concerned are you that if Putin
gets Ukraine then that seriously redraws
uh the map
um vis-a-vis Russia and NATO
such a good question and so important
that we keep that in mind because this
boldness that Putin is showing is
because he's gotten by with Georgia and
Crimea and now he is doing the exact
same thing that he has done before and
if we don't show the strength to push
back and be stronger than we were
because we were so surprised in the
first two
um then I think he is going to be
emboldened to go further possibly into
the baltics OR Poland uh possibly from
Belarus into Kiev and it is so important
that we stand firm right now and I I do
think that what Germany has done uh has
to be complemented and called out that
they have now finally said we're not
going to do Nordstrom too unless we see
a complete Retreat from what he has done
right today uh that is probably the
biggest incentive of all uh because it
is a revenue stream that Putin needs for
all of his malign activity
I mean do you think uh Kay that NATO
could do enough to deter Putin
well I certainly think that we are
sending the signals uh and President
Biden mentioned the Black Sea and that
is something that we haven't talked
about very much but the uh Patrols in
the Black Sea uh also are uh escalating
and the countries that are in NATO there
like Romania like
um uh Bulgaria and turkey all then have
to be looking also at the Black Sea so
now that we see that he has taken this
step with Ukraine we have to assume that
that nothing is off the table for him
and we have to act accordingly with
strength and commitment and that that's
what NATO is doing right now by
increasing our troops in the baltics
we've already done so in Poland and now
we are going to be watching the Black
Sea very carefully
and Anders just back to sanctions it's
often said that uh sanctions don't
really impact President Putin it said
that you know now that his economy can
withstand whatever sanctions the West
impose is that true
no it's not true Russia has not had any
economic growth from 2014 to 2020 when
Central and East in Europe by and large
group by four to five percent a year so
Russia has suffered massively from the
financial sanctions in particular and
it's another part of your question and
that is really deter President Putin no
because Putin doesn't care about the
economy or the population this has not
impressed him at all he put out a plan
one and a half years ago for the next 10
years predicting New Economic growth at
all there are no attempts to reform the
economy or to modernize the to the
economy it's all about defense and and
repression so Putin has really turned
into a complete tyrant in the first two
items he provided a high economic growth
or rather he was lucky because he
arrived at the late Table after the hard
reforms in the 1990s and then came the
oil boom but after 2009 Russia has
hardly had any growth and real
disposable income the standard of living
failed by 11 during the last seven years
so Putin doesn't care about that in 2008
the stock market fell by 80 from May to
October was the President Putin
impressed not the least in 2014 after
the Western sanctions had been imposed
and after the war in
eastern Ukraine had started
the value of the Russian Ruble fell by
more than half so what reporting was not
the impressed rest so it's rather than
President Putin gets less of economic
resources for his defense
Russia spends about six percent of its
gross domestic product on defense and it
can hardly spend more than that and that
is the limitation not what happens to
the the economy and what happens to the
population
okay just a minute or so left I just
want to ask sir Roderick and Kay in
particular where they think this is
heading so sir Roderick what I mean look
it's I know how difficult it is to
predict these things but what is your
hunch about how this may play out
well the position that Putin is in at
the moment doesn't really make any kind
of sense
um either he's got to go further and he
could go down towards the Black Sea or
he could go to Kiev or he's got to seek
to take some winnings by stopping where
he is and trying to negotiate and is
anybody's guess as to what he does but
it's important for him to remember there
are a lot of very very unhappy people in
Russia and he's taking a big risk which
could rebound against him personally
and just so quickly it's the Roderick do
you think there's a possibility that he
could sort of leave it where he is and
say look I mean he had his big speech
obviously he had the big security
council meeting in public I mean is it
possible he may want a way out now and
just decide yes it is possible this is
it you had General David Petraeus on a
bit earlier who who was also pointing
out it is absolutely possible Putin
could declare a victory he said I've now
recognized uh the independence of
Donetsk and lugan's people's republics
uh I've put the West on the defensive uh
he would then see perhaps some further
gains if he can
um he has that option he hasn't
foreclosed that option yet uh but
whether he will take it or not as I say
uh you're all guessing at what's inside
Putin's head and nobody knows that
possibly Putin doesn't know that
no okay well just 30 seconds left in K
Bailey Hutcherson I mean do you think
there's a possibility of a negotiated uh
settlement here or do you fear he is
going to push on and do what he wants to
do with Ukraine
well I think he I agree with what we
said before
I think he would negotiate but I don't
think and I think he may well have just
wanted to get those two and hold them
just like he's done in Georgia and
solidify those gains but he is not going
to ever be able to negotiate that this
will be part of Russia that will not be
accepted just like Crimea is not being
accepted as Russian it is Ukraine and
like the two provinces in Georgia are
still Georgia even though the Russians
now require teaching of Russian in the
schools they have border patrols and
Border controls uh on the two provinces
that they have illegally taken I think
they could well say this is a victory
all I really wanted was the two
provinces and walk away but never will
they be able to get the Ukraine's and
president zielinski to say okay we'll
make a deal you can have them the the
people do not want that in Ukraine they
are Fierce uh for Crimea and they don't
want to give up eastern part of their
country and they are wonderful people
who are so committed to a free and open
and fair treatment uh country for
Ukraine
okay Kay Bailey Hutchison and Anders
Aslan and also sir Roderick line uh
thank you all very much indeed
foreign
placing sanctions on two Russian Banks
and targeting the Russian Elite Joe
Biden says that he hopes uh diplomacy is
still available but speaking this
afternoon Vladimir Putin rejected claims
he was to blame for the crisis and he
issued a list of Demands calling for
Crimea to be recognized as part of
Russia a halt to weapons shipments to
Ukraine and an end to the country's bid
to join NATO well let's get some
reflection on the last 24 hours now our
security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes is also here in Kiev and
reflection on 24 hours the last 24 hours
Deborah but also looking ahead these are
dangerous hours and dangerous days
yes it's hard it's hard to imagine that
at the beginning of yesterday people
were talking about the possible hope of
a diplomatic breakthrough thanks to the
French president's telephone efforts
over the weekend trying to conjure up
some kind of summit perhaps between Joe
Biden and President Vladimir Putin but
since then the day ended didn't it with
Russian with the Russian president
recognizing the independence of those
two separatist-held territories and
saying that he'll be sending Russian
so-called peacekeepers into those
territories in a significant escalation
of a crisis that British and American
leaders have warned could lead to an
all-out invasion of Ukraine but to offer
a different perspective I went and met
the Estonian president today he actually
flew into Kiev especially in a show of
solidarity with the Ukrainian president
and pre and prime minister who he met
wanting them to know that he believes
that the the daughter NATO and the EU
must never be closed to countries like
Ukraine we can have a listen to a bit of
that interview
how worried are you that what we're
seeing in the East is um the beginning
of the invasion so it's already started
it is the beginning of a feeling amazing
but do we hope it will also end there so
this is where was also my main message
because we started and we will start
with the sanctions U.S UK as well as
European union and I hope this will stop
this kind of escalation and protein will
start thinking what he has done and what
might happen in in future in the US and
the UK have been very open in the fact
they build they do believe that there
will be a full-scale Invasion so do you
disagree with that
I talked to Ukrainian prime minister and
also to president they don't think this
would happen probably they have their
own information sources so um
what I can say is we hope it won't
happen so let's see
and do you think though that if
President Putin is successful in taking
control at least of Ukraine that he
could then turn his eyes wider and maybe
look at the Baltic states
as I said if he tries to look wider he's
looking at NATO
and it's not the Baltic states Estonia
or any other country it's in NATO and
that's that's a different story as I
said and I guess the UK embassies moved
why haven't you moved your Embassy from
Kiev
because from my opinion is that
ambassadors and embassies should stay on
the front line in these kind of
situations
so a little dig there at the British and
the Americans that have left their
embassies here in Kiev but very much
united front by the Europeans and the US
in this escalating crisis
Deborah thank you very much indeed while
we're on air Joe Biden announced
sanctions against uh Russia this is Sky
News Tonight coming up in the next hour
the West responds with sanctions saying
the Russian invasion of Ukraine has
begun much more at the top of the hour
[Music]
foreign
[Music]